but everyone with a period's a woman and
not all women have periods and that's
why we need inclusive language we didn't
want to leave you hanging with no clips
so here's just some general Insanity of
the day not everyone with a periods a
woman and not all women have periods and
that's why we need inclusive language
let's talk about it okay let's start off
with the fact that not just women have
periods many people can have periods
this is some transgender men some
non-binary people some two spirit folks
some gender non-conforming folks some
gender fluid folks on that same note not
all women have periods like some
transgender women women that have had
hysterectomies women with endometriosis
PC
we need to separate bodily function from
gender how we can do this is using
inclusive language things like period
products instead of feminine hygiene
saying people with periods instead of
just women when it comes to periods
talking about reproductive health and
uterine Health not Women's Health what
this sets out to do is to include
everybody in the conversation because I
think we can all agree everybody
deserves to have safe and accessible
information when it comes to their
bodies here's some other inclusive
language switches that you can consider
making to make it a more inclusive
accessible
world